up until this lesson we're certified by
looking at service area how much 2d
space fits around the 3d shape you're
looking at 2d space fitting around a 3d
shape now dealing with 3d shapes we're
gonna deal with a 3d measure about the
shape which is volumes so we're gonna
sort of rewind go back to the beginning
of our shapes and instead of going
surface area surface area surface area
we are going to inspect all these kinds
of shapes for volume ok so here's an
example this is about as simple as it
can get this is a what is the name of
the shape again a rectangular prism
thank you very much and you can see I
haven't drawn in the edges that are
hidden yet so let's do that now and what
you've got here is pretty
straightforward to evaluate what does
volume me volume is about how much 3d
space does something occupied okay now
in this case it's actually really simple
because if you're at all and if you have
another color that we really what you
but is this rectangle on the fun copy
over and over and over again like slices
of red all the way back every time you
slice you get that same shape so the
volume of this is clearly going to
depend on that cross section so I'm
going to write V equals now I know a lot
of you can actually leap straight
through the answer or even the working
requirement yet but I wanted to note for
you that there are these two components
there's the cross section
right that area that's the first place
you've got to start that's what makes
the prism a prism
why do you multiply that by the
cross-section here if we call it that
four by three on the front if I call
this the cross-section what would I
multiply that by in terms of numbers to
get the volume yeah I mean yeah okay so
I guess you could sort of color the
bread or the depth or something like
that or laying really maybe even with
its kind of weed when you don't really
know where you're measuring from I'm
gonna give you an even read of word
which no one has said yet but it's
actually the most helpful I'm going to
call this the height now you would look
at that say all the words to choose y
height we unambiguously use height to
meet up and down right but I'm gonna
push on this a little bit remember one
really can't rhyme in fact the one I
just gave I think I gave you like a five
over here and what was that six plus
three or something that's mine now you
remember when we put the shape like this
I gave you one yesterday I believe where
I gave you this length and it's not the
height is it right you can't use that
the area what are you gonna do there you
go work out this guy the real height not
missing poster hi what makes this height
more important what is it there's a
feature I'm not drawing on its
perpendicular right so it's not just
high high it's just kind of shorthand
for perpendicular height
now have a look at this triangle what is
the height perpendicular to where wait
come back over here he are when I say
that's the perpendicular height this God
why he is not perpendicular everything
it's not happen to do this or this what
is it perpendicular to the base very
good so you've got to think about which
feature are you measuring from now in
our prison what it's perpendicular to is
not the base this node like which shape
is weak it's perpendicular to cross
sections are funnier than I thought
now the reason why I put that out is
because depending on how you shape has
been drawing that perpendicular height
if you're lucky it might go up down just
like most Heights do all like in this
diagram
it might go into the diagram or sideways
or anything you've got to look for where
the cross section is and then measure
okay now the reason why this works is
because if you think about said shape
okay so this is like this guy let me
hold it right there we go you see three
four and do it right that's six across
yeah what you're doing is you're saying
look each cross section I can work out
independently and I know I'm just gonna
keep on getting patched the cross
section catch over and over again no I
I'm gonna get it over and over again
right so it's literally let's do the
numbers now in this thing this one
what's the cross-section it's 3 times 4
right and how many of them do I have
after those ones I threw away I would
have had six of those cross sections
yeah and that's why 12 by 6 that's 72
and this is cubic centimeters okay so
the reason why I highlight this right
and just go straight to the numbers
right is because this helps us
understand this way of understanding you
work with any prism even prisms that are
like what on earth is this called I
don't know like a Tetris shape prism oh
no it's still a prism why is it still a
prism because if you go way back job
well that's less than you guys right
yeah you sure
our very first lesson we said so long as
your cross-section all the way the same
to prison which is why even though it
sort of follows different rules
we are lumping together cylinders with
prisms this time okay because a cylinder
like a prism has a consistent
cross-section it's just the
cross-section happens to be a circle so
your cross-section you put like you
don't need to write this but you put a
PI R squared there and then you'd
multiply by the perpendicular height
which is why the volume of a cylinder is
PI R squared H or whatever it is today
does that make sense